this is a Wendover productions video
made possible by Squarespace
make your next move with a beautiful
website from Squarespace the Cumberland
Valley is home to six towns lying
between Hagerstown Maryland and
Harrisburg Pennsylvania
Green Castle Chambersburg Shippensburg
neuville Carlisle and Mechanicsburg
what's exceptional about these small
Pennsylvania towns is that they're each
almost exactly ten miles from each other
the distances deviate by no more than a
mile from this rule this isn't a
coincidence
and this isn't planned drawing equal
sized radii around each town shows you
their spheres of influence assuming each
town has the exact same shops and
services rational people will go to
whichever town is closest to buy or sell
goods counts 10 miles apart mean that
nobody has to travel more than five
miles to reach a town each one of these
towns was founded before the formation
of the United States so that means that
of course nobody had cars and pretty
much everybody walked everywhere ten
miles or five miles each way is about
the distance a person can comfortably
walk in a day with enough time to buy or
sell goods at a central market back in
this era before cars a five-mile radius
was essentially the largest possible
commuter zone to small agricultural
towns and therefore having towns ten
miles apart was the most efficient
possible use of rural land when you get
the chance take a look at a map of a
rural area that existed before cars
you'll see that the distance between
medium-sized towns is almost always
somewhere between about ten to fifteen
miles because the Cumberland Valley is a
valley town who really could only
develop in a line but in most cases
towns develop in all directions this is
what the ten mile rule looks like when
going out in all directions each of
these points is a town and the hexagon
around it is the area from which people
will go to the town in the real world
each of these towns probably has a small
grocery store a pharmacy a bank and
maybe a restaurant since everybody uses
these services there doesn't have to be
many people in a town sphere of
influence in order to sustain these
shops but where do you put something
more specialized like a mechanic
people only need to go to the mechanic
every once in a while so you need more
people to sustain one mechanic shop than
one grocery store well some of these
small towns develop into larger towns
with more people that can support more
specialized shops and services putting
these larger towns with more specialized
shops closer together would be
unsustainable since there wouldn't be
enough people going to those shops but
putting them farther apart would be
inefficient since there's land that
people would not go to a city from this
happens once or twice more until you
have cities these cities have the
largest spheres of influence and the
most specialized shops you of course
still have grocery stores and pharmacies
in cities but you also have things like
luxury car dealerships brain surgery
centers and airports the cities sphere
of influence is enormous because people
will travel hundreds of miles to buy an
expensive car or get brain surgery or
fly from an airport think about it
within a city how far would you walk to
buy a lot I'm probably only a few blocks
and that's why you see Starbucks or
other coffee shops on almost every block
since almost everyone buys coffee you
only need a few blocks of people to
sustain one coffee shop but how far
would you walk to buy a Macbook probably
quite far since it's an infrequent and
substantial purchase
that's why Apple stores are rather rare
even in cities you need an enormous
amount of people to sustain one Apple
store and we can actually figure out
roughly how many in Connecticut the
Trumbull Apple store is about 20 miles
away from the New Haven store to the
Northeast
and the Stanford store to the southwest
in the ten mile radius around the
Trumbull Apple store there are about
half a million inhabitants which tells
us that you need about half a million
people to sustain one Apple store we can
compare that to the Starbucks's of lower
Manhattan which are spread out at an
average distance of about 600 feet
drawing a 300 foot radius around one
Starbucks in lower Manhattan covers
about 6,000 people which means that one
Starbucks needs 6,000 people to sustain
it of course both Connecticut and New
York are places with higher than average
incomes which means that less people are
needed to sustain one Starbucks or Apple
Store the numbers would be very
different in
a rural Kansas but since each store
generally only builds in areas with
higher than average incomes this gives a
good sense of how many people Apple and
Starbucks look for in an area before
opening up a store
so our model shows where cities should
be but it's not like this in reality
this is the most efficient spread of
cities if you're assuming that cities
are on a perfectly flat plane with no
geographic features no social influences
no variability of income equal
distribution of resources essentially
assuming the world is one homogeneous
place which is not in reality of course
our world has an enormous effect on
where and why cities develop to start
out let's cut this down to one city on a
flat featureless plain for simplicity
what affects the location of cities more
than anything is water if we put an
ocean on one side of our isotropic plane
our city will almost certainly locate
near it oceans have always been and
still are what connects the world
there's no other means of transport that
can move such enormous amounts of cargo
for so little any city needs to be
economically efficient to grow and it
will cost more to bring goods to a city
that's a thousand miles inland than one
right by the ocean just look at Europe
six of the ten largest European cities
are within 100 miles of the coast but
oceans aren't the only bodies of water
to affect cities rivers are just as or
perhaps even more influential Milan the
19th largest European city is the
largest to not be either directly on the
ocean or on a river and even then is
only 15 miles from a river and 75 miles
from the ocean until the last century or
so cities could not survive without
direct water access if you need more
proof 14 of the 15 largest cities in the
world are within a few dozen miles of
the ocean perhaps the most obvious
attractor for cities is resources so
going back to our isotropic plane
putting natural resources anywhere on
this map will draw cities near cities
that existed before the last century or
so generally sprung up right near the
resources much like Pittsburgh since
they acted as manufacturing and
transportation hubs
for those resources but more recently
new resource dependent cities don't need
to be as close to the resources
themselves new transportation
technologies can bring the resources
from their source just look at Dubai
of course the UAE has enormous oil
deposits but they're much closer to Abu
Dhabi and the Southwest than Dubai in
1900 Dubai had 10,000 residents less
than half that of Carlisle Pennsylvania
one of the farming towns we talked about
at the beginning that only grew to
40,000 by 1960 but today it's known
worldwide and has more than 2.5 million
residents it was able to grow at this
enormous rate even faster than Abu Dhabi
since it cemented itself as the economic
and administrative hub for the oil
industries of the region another
geographic feature that we can add to
the plane is mountains now mountains
don't always have a uniform effect on
cities Mexico City Bogota and Addis
Ababa are all enormous cities at
elevations above 7000 feet
mountains do make transport and trade
difficult but they also provide
protection many ancient cities grew in
these locations since they were easy to
protect which left more time to focus on
growing the city but mountains can also
hinder development for quite a while the
United States could not develop west of
the Appalachian Mountains they just
served as an enormous barrier in 1800
the average center of population for the
entire United States was here even
though the US had sovereignty over this
entire area of course technology
eventually conquered this barrier and
move the mean population center all the
way out to Missouri today but if the
Appalachian Mountains didn't exist
American history and geography would be
completely different we would have seen
urban development much earlier in the
Midwest but mountains can also have
another effect you see coal silver gold
and other mineral deposits are all often
located in mountainous regions and just
like Dubai cities can develop in less
hospitable and easy places due to
resources the economic advantage of
exploiting the resources overpowers the
economic disadvantage of being in an
inhospitable location Denver
Colorado grew 650 percent between 1870
and 1880 with the opening of a railroad
branch connecting with a
transcontinental railroad it served as
an access point to transportation to the
gold miners in the Rockies so mountains
can either push cities away or bring
them nearer it really just depends on
the circumstance let's exchange your
isotropic plane for a world map where
should cities beyond here well our
world's cities are not necessarily in
all the most geographically efficient
locations while there is a certain level
of natural selection that grows the
efficiently place cities and shrinks the
inefficiently play cities humans are not
always able to put cities in the most
efficient locations let's put up the 224
cities in the world with a population
over 2 million you can immediately see
some patterns putting up the equator you
can see there's a clear divide only 32
of these cities lie in the southern
hemisphere one might think that this is
because there's so much more land in the
northern hemisphere but that's not
entirely true you see the southern
hemisphere still has 32 percent of the
world's land but only has 14 percent of
the world's large cities there's clearly
a higher density of cities in the
northern hemisphere you can pretty much
trace this all back to Europe and Asia
the first large civilizations and
empires were on these two continents
even though the human race likely
originated in Africa there's hundreds of
different theories on why civilizations
succeeded in some places and failed in
others but one of the more plausible and
interesting theories is that Europe and
Asia succeeded because they're wide
instead of tall the very shape of
continents may have changed the course
of human history
you see when a continent is wide you
have a ton of land with roughly the same
climate climate tends to change when you
go north and south rather than east and
west as a nature of how the earth
rotates around the Sun much of the
success of early civilizations had to do
with the domestication of plants and
animals and the corresponding technology
when expanding horizontally the climate
is similar enough that an empire can use
the same successful plants and animals
while expanding vertically requires the
domestication of new
plants and animals if a civilization
started in Central America for example
there would be very little land on the
continent with a similar climate and
their expansion would be severely
limited in Europe and Asia on the other
hand there's thousands upon thousands of
miles of similar climate that can be
reached just by traveling east or west
just look at the maps of the four
largest early empires the ching dynasty
the abbasid caliphate the Umayyad
caliphate and the mongol empire they
were all in Eurasia and they all
expanded horizontally when some of the
more modern empires expanded they had
the technology to do so overseas the
three major modern empires were the
British Spanish and French empires each
of which came from relatively similar
climates a major reason why America was
able to succeed is because all the
agriculture from Europe worked there
climactically Europe and America are
nearly identical
the majority of developed colonized
countries are in the northern hemisphere
just because they were closest to Europe
but formerly British countries like
South Africa Australia and New Zealand
are all highly developed and in the
southern hemisphere their success over
more northern countries in the southern
hemisphere can also be partially
attributed to their greater climate
similarity to Europe let's ask one more
question if our world only had one city
where would it logically be well if you
take the location of every person in the
world and average it out you come to
South Central Asia that means that this
general region is the optimum place to
live on the planet but where more
specifically should our world city go
well this region is already in the
northern hemisphere and in Eurasia
so we've already covered those two
criteria we want a place within a
hundred or so miles of the ocean on a
navigable river near mountains with rich
mineral deposits the single best place
for a city on earth just might be Dhaka
Bangladesh every Geographic model and
theory says that there is no better
place on earth to put a city than here
there's evidence to back this up Dhaka
is between the fourth and the 18th
largest metropolitan area
on earth depending on how you define
metropolitan area and Bangladesh is this
six dentist country on earth there are a
hundred and sixty 1 million people
living in an area of about the size of
England history has affected geography
enough that the largest and most
advanced civilizations are not all in
South Central Asia but if we started all
over again
did humanity a second time every
Geographic model says that this region
could be the origin and central point of
human civilization I hope you enjoyed
this one dover productions video this
video was made possible by my amazing
brand new sponsor Squarespace
Squarespace is an all-in-one platform to
make your beautiful professional website
months before Squarespace signed on to
sponsor Wendover productions I use them
to make my website Wendover productions
calm now I wasn't looking for anything
fancy I just wanted to make sure that
nobody else could get their hands on the
Wendover production comm domain and also
to create a great-looking landing page
this way I could give people one link
that goes to all my different social
accounts I know that most of you guys
are smart upstart entrepreneurial people
that want to make your mark and what's
so much more professional than a
LinkedIn or Twitter or Facebook account
is a standalone website and it's cheaper
than you think especially because if you
sign up using the links squarespace.com
slash Wendover and use the code Wendover
in your order you'll get 10% off this is
hopefully the beginning of a long and
prosperous relationship between Wendover
productions and Squarespace
they're really committed to helping
independent creators like me and perhaps
you make great things so definitely take
a look at what they have to offer and
make your next move with Squarespace you
can support Wendover productions by
contributing on patreon we're a hundred
percent of the funds go right back into
the channel I even release expense
reports at the end of each month you can
also get great rewards over there like
early access to videos stickers
handwritten letters and most recently
t-shirts you can also order a t-shirt by
itself for only $20 through dftba the
link is here and also in the description
other than that please make sure to
follow me on twitter at 1-over pro watch
my last video on every country in the
world he
check out my fan moderated subreddit
here and most of all subscribe to this
channel to receive all my future videos
right when they come out thanks again
for watching and I'll see you in two
weeks for another Wendover productions
video